do you really want me to read my text
messages kind of find thousands
thousands
okay here we go okay she says knock it
off leave me out of your bullet press do
you have zero knowledge of who i am okay
go away
wait and she didn't stop there
the dos amigas
back on tv
was it like riding a bike
or was there a learning curve doing
ultimate girls trip i think there was a
learning curve because we were filming
with people we'd never met i agree i
agree with that 100 percent but it
definitely two years a year and a half i
think we were off
housewives it definitely took us you
know it was like riding a bike but it
took us a little time to warm up
although this one gets in a fight in the
very first episode didn't mean to but
i'm gonna stand you never do
oh it's not i don't ever fight with
anybody
when you saw the list of who would be
there with you
what name stuck out as i'm excited about
that one and did anybody stick out as i
do not want to spend time with her for
me i knew originally i was an ass to be
on the show
i got asked at the very last minute and
i still don't know why because i got
coveted and they thought they were not
going to be able to use me so i was
supposed to be a replacement probably oh
probably i mean i don't blame them so i
had known that vicki was going on it and
there was rumors of the cast and all i
thought at that time was thank god they
didn't ask me because brandi glanville's
on it and i don't want to film with her
because she scares the bejesus out of me
and because we had like this online
feud i think
i might have been responsible for that
yeah our very first interview was right
after brandy got fired
okay i was a little bit shocked at that
and she says it was her choice
nobody leaves the housewife show nobody
yes i mean brandi and i had and you'll
see it and i think the very first
episode
that we have this relationship that
wasn't an online relationship that
wasn't that great and vicki eva marcel
was very excited to meet you
you had no idea who she was
you still don't after a week of living
with you
i know who she is
just by being with her but i don't know
anything about her i don't know well she
was on the real housewives of atlanta
she was i never taught she won didn't
she yeah she won america's next top
model i don't know that you just told me
some new information
was she the only person you didn't know
or was there more on that list that you
went who is this i know everybody else
well i think that there was people that
we knew of like i knew who eva was i
never had met dorinda before can you
tell that truth a unicorn's gonna show
up birds of a feather flock together i
am not flocking with that bird
totally disappointed me she we were in
her home in the middle of nowhere
oh here we go is going to love this it
doesn't matter it's the facts she's
we're in the berkshires and it's fine it
works for her i just said it doesn't
work for me but i thought being in her
home she would be much more gracious and
you agreed
oh dodgy i'll be throwing me under the
bus
listen she had a tough job she has to
you know accommodate all accommodate
everybody it was tough it was tough it
would have been a tough job we should
have gone to a hotel like turks and
caicos oh
just saying but instead we go with the
middle of nowhere why is that offensive
well mean there's very famous people
that like i get it i get it it i just
said that works for them it doesn't work
for me you it is the middle of nowhere i
think it was your message your delivery
it was your delivery not so much
yourself you missed delivery like you
have everything delivered perfectly no i
didn't say that i'm saying sometimes the
delivery
let me let me clear the air
i said it works for her it's a beautiful
home it's great for her it wouldn't work
for me that's it all right well it's
sparked this entire back and forth
didn't want to go because she wanted to
be like
engaged with the og she can keep coming
at me i don't really care
she told me that she has received
thousands of text messages from you in
the last couple weeks i got thousands of
taxes from her
what do those say
not nice things thousands i got the text
message probably like four four to six
what did you say what do those say i
said
move on when you're reading
do you really want me to read a text
message kinda kind thousands thousands
okay
okay a little stressed out
jeremiah
d-o-r-i-dorinda
okay here we go is this thousands this
is me that was a lot of scrolling vicky
no this is october 17th we're going back
okay we've gotten okay i'm going to when
did this start when did this feud start
friday i said knock it off because she
said
okay she said knock it off but she also
surrendered screenshot screenshot of
what jeremy was saying
is accusing vicki goldstein of dating
people that pretend to have cancer you
may not like my life but i also don't
date people that pretend to have cancer
so you know what i mean and she slams
real house of ultimate girls trip
co-star of lack of manners and says she
has no taste
so how is this living out in nowhere
have no time so vicky says you have no
idea the torment and money i went
through with brooks shame on you
we shouldn't stop there
leave me out of your bullet press so you
have zero knowledge of who i am okay
i own four houses my own business for 32
years and no one gifted me anything go
away
go away
wait and she didn't stop there okay
maybe not thousands but we're still
going you made everyone miserable at
your home also you may want to what's
that re-listen to my interview i never
said anything about
you or you're bad about your home
nothing about bad about your home or you
i said if you're happy that's all that
matters i also said it's old
and in the middle of nowhere and
wouldn't work for me whether it's
historic or not it's still old
exclamation mark any response from
dorinda why don't you talk about that
is it a bad thing that it's old get
control of your temper vicky says you
are mean person and you didn't make it
nice
for many of us she said
okay
yep i was gifted a beautiful manner
lucky me that's dirinda you know what
you said and the people have responded
and i mean i mean it's not it was no
it's it's two more text messages and
that's it so how did you can you tell us
how you left it she says i'm at my
daughter's graduation we're celebrating
her going to whatever whatever um so she
diverted i never said it was bad i never
said it was
she seemed to take issue with the
gifting part to be
going on about in texas to me that all
that was gifted to you or whatever
i just find the sentiment towards it
very negative i mean it wasn't
frankly gifted to me i mean my husband
died and we owned the house together so
i don't know where else it would have
gone unless he had some sort of mistress
i didn't know about you know what i mean
i only told her that i never told the
press that okay where did you get gifted
from she told us no you said i've never
been gifted anything in my life i've
always worked for things
and so she took it as you're saying that
the house that she lives in and the
virgin offenders
no i'm trying to relate what was being
said you know what i mean
somebody asked me on the interview
what do you think of dorinda's house
what makes dorinda happy would never
make me happy so i think that's what
you're gonna see is um her living out in
this
old house in the middle of nowhere i
would be freaking miserable like i said
it's old in the middle of nowhere and it
is old and it is in the middle of
nowhere how is that a lie you're not
going back to the berkshires anytime
soon no desire there's nothing to do
there any chance that you and dorinda
can get to a place of i'll be kind of
nice to her
well you're going to see her tuesday
those type of people don't enter the
gates of my life because i don't trust
her now i think she's mean we filmed
with her for a week and it was awful so
i just interviewed her and i said you
have a message for vicki and she said
any um words to share with her
see at the premiere party but almost in
a threatening way oh whatever she can
sit down
i'm not threatened by her why would i be
threatened
that's weird she's gonna even do when
you see her say hi to him
how's your old house
listen
oh my god i'm gonna go ballistic on this
one
if a house is old or uh what is it um
historic historic is a historic home old
yes yes
is it in the middle of nowhere
yes never been so i it is it's in the so
why is that a bad thing well it's miles
between houses okay it's in the middle
and it's in the it's like i think she
doesn't have a miss defender okay i'm
just try
i love you
i can tell
no it's just weird that's why you make a
fight about that if i lived in an old
house in the middle of nowhere and
somebody said that i'd be like yeah i do
i live in an old house in the middle of
nowhere why is it a problem do you think
she just did this too i think she tried
to
carry on to keep herself relevant that's
how i see this well it has people paying
attention they'll be trying to well i
feel like people are going to be tuning
in just to see the fight between you and
jordan which happens in the first
episode and i think carrie's out
over the next six seven hours it's not
nice she made her cry she made me she
may have been make you cry well you got
to watch you gotta watch and see she
made everybody in the place cry but i
think eva phaedra cried i mean everybody
cried i don't remember crying it was a
nightmare
you